it is a very dear pleasure and privilege
to be here it's not often that your
mentors calling you can you come and
it's hard to say no to dairy after he
helped train me in medicine during those
days that we were we've often recalled
you also heard from him about the
uniform on ie I'm telling people I it
looks like as I approached the end of my
career in public health i find myself
explaining myself what is a uniform non
not in the Navy I'm not a delta pilot
this is the US Public Health Service
that has been around since 1789 we're a
non-combatant force that really fights
disease not people so I'm proud to be
part of the Public Health Service and
the other thing is having you explained
working TV because everyone my relatives
included and TV is it still around some
it looks like you just need to explain a
lot of what I do my overview is broken
into these three parts i will first of
all ask your forbearance and forgiveness
because i'm sure that many of you
sitting here could do that background
that i'm going to touch it on i'm going
to try to move us rapidly through it
then talk about the epidemiology of
tuberculosis in both the United States
and the globe talking about the
resurgence that was unprecedented in our
country and the recovery that has ensued
over the last 20 years then from a very
personal perspective not necessarily
sanctioned by the Public Health Service
what I think is going to need to happen
and we're going to do good on the
promise to eliminate tuberculosis so the
quick snapshot is at TB has been present
and documented and mummified remains
from Egypt dating back to 2,000 years
before Common Era if you read
Hippocrates he first comes up with the
term thesis to describe consumption fast
forward
and over the 200 years between 1700 1900
global TV deaths were estimated at 1
billion with a be in the year when
Robert [ __ ] announced his discovery of
the tubercle bacillus March 24th 1882
there were seven million deaths that
year and and TV still continues to claim
too many lives up shown in here is
actually the manuscript I noticed that
his publication is only a few months
after his presentation that was really
amazing you know that clearance nowadays
that it takes a longer 90 does 36 uh
there's a the TB culture becomes the
gold standard in diagnosis by 43
southern Watchmen and colleagues and New
Jersey discover streptomycin which is
licensed and introduced for use a year
later then this other slide which
doesn't really show very well in here
has all the other drugs that were
developed for tuberculosis is the last
one of being licensed in 1968 then you
have what occurred in the 1980s which is
a convergence of HIV and tuberculosis
and I will pause here and share with you
something that I heard from Jim Curran
who I worked for now Dean of the Emory
wrong school of medicine when i finished
my briefing of what we were observing in
the united states he said so Ken what
you need to tell me is that TB and HIV
hang out together and they're a bad
influence on each other I said you got
it and in many ways he actually for so
what became self evident the years later
to others here's the single slide that's
going to turn you into TB experts with
transmission and pathophysiology so in
the left you see airborne droplet nuclei
that are generated by anyone who has
tuberculosis in the respiratory system
or in the vocal
ords when they cough and the airborne
droplet nucleate are unique in that
there 125 micron and as size they remain
suspended in air as opposed to when you
spit that the gravity to bring that to
the floor remaining suspended in air
means that anyone who's nearby will
inhale these bacteria especially of the
ventilation is for air is stagnant
anyone who's susceptible can inhale
these bacilli and then you have what
happens to most individuals which is the
establishment of latent infection by
definition these persons have no
symptoms you find them through screening
using tuberculin tests nowadays you can
use some interferon gamma release
athletes such as a tea spot or quanta
furin a small fraction will go to
develop TB disease and many of the
reservoir of latent ly infected also
developed the seas it's thought to be
about five to ten percent lifetime risk
that anyone with infection will develop
disease factors that accelerate its
progression at the top of the list are
eight of the associated immunodeficiency
other factors that are iatrogenic in
nature are immunodeficiency induced by
the use of TNF alpha blockers that we're
now using to treat people with
rheumatoid arthritis and many of you who
listen to the ads on television if you
have ever had tuberculosis your doctor
dough before you get started on humira
or any of these poorly controlled
diabetes cancer chemotherapy longs to
term high-dose steroids now if you have
latent TB the intervention is using
treatment with ionizer for latent
tuberculosis under the diagram of the
human body there I mentioned that BCG
vaccine introduced it in the 1920s has
been used throughout the world and it's
thought to be about seventy to eighty
percent of your cases in preventing the
dissemination of disease in children in
adults at
coin toss about 50% efficacy and not
consistent nor reliable once persons
developed the season the two things we
have to do our treat them or and
implement infection control precautions
if they develop cavity lesions and when
they cough then they're going to
aerosolize and therefore start the cycle
that's it you know everything you need
to know about tuberculosis before
antibiotics that became available what
did we do to people so i'm showing here
the cover art of this month's issue of
emerging infectious diseases that has a
TV theme it's a painting called TB
Harlem 1940 by Alice deal it depicts the
brother of person who she lived with and
I was I don't know if she was married to
him but she had a couple of children by
him and this person is someone who had
just completed a thoracotomy for his
tuberculosis so you see the man she
aided person with a deformed test and
this is what we had to offer fairly
destructive as surgical interventions
then then the lower slide is a color
version of sanatorium where people were
brought to inhale fresh air and it was
thought that those had curative
properties but we do know that that was
not sufficient there are a number of
individuals who seem to spontaneously
heal their tuberculosis we don't know
who they are and that you can't reliably
identify them but they in the good old
days of they used to be called the
chronic lung nurse they would remain
alive and occasionally be the source of
transmission they would heal and all
sudden the unit would start spitting
blood because they had reactivation of
their disease here's what we now have in
our armamentarium the photograph shows
Selman Waksman and his colleagues
streptomycin at the top of the list
licensed in 1944
or I don't include in the list Caprio
myosin cycle Syrian and other agents but
they're all developed within the
timeframe of 1944 296 1968 so for those
of us who worked on AIDS and seeing the
advent of antiretrovirals to the point
that I can't keep up with them I find it
embarrassing that we haven't had a
single new TB drugs since 1968 and it's
something that we have had to address
and i will further comment on that the
goals of modern day management of
tuberculosis is to rely on multi drug
regimens for both the individual and the
public at the individual level the idea
is to prevent suffering disability and
deaths by killing bacteria rapidly
that's the initial face that has at
least four drugs and prevent relapse due
to persistent bacilli and that's where
you have the continuation phase of
therapy you also want to prevent the
selection of drug resistance by using
multiple drugs the public health
benefits are to prevent transmission by
identifying contacts in need of
treatment for their latent tuberculosis
or you also find very often among
contact people with TB disease in need
of treatment and the other thing is to
protect these drug regimens for future
generations this slide you're not meant
to read but there the extent regulations
for treatment of tuberculosis due to
drug susceptible disease and they
basically consist of the drugs isoniazid
rifampin pairs nmit and ethambutol used
either daily or intermittently during an
initial in a continuation face that
lasts a total of six months and the
recommendations are listed for HIV
negative and HIV positive like placed
asterisk next to the contract occasions
of associated with the use of highly
intermittent therapy in hiv-infected
it's not recommended because of the high
risk of relapse especially with
drug-resistant the seas of cd4 counts
are less
than a hundred but this busy slide is
summarized by used for drunks in during
the first two months followed by two
drugs for the following four months for
a total of six months if people have
bilateral cavitary disease or remain
culture positive at the end of the
initial face you will in all likelihood
need to extend the continuation phase
two seven months rather than the four
months to achieve a cure let's now talk
about drug-resistant tuberculosis this
slide was originally prepared by peter
segal ski who works with us and i find
it very useful to conceptualize what we
talk about when we define multi and
extensively drug-resistant TB in essence
when you have multi drug-resistant TB by
definition you've lost the two most
important drugs in the first line
regimen isoniazid and rifampin xdr-tb is
a subpopulation of MDR that has in
addition lost the two best second line
drugs that's the injectables like Caprio
meissen allocation and kanamycin and the
fluoroquinolones why do we make such a
fuss over it because it requires
treatment with real Aussie drugs are
less potent more toxic and you need to
treat people for a long period of time
you're going to drive some of them deaf
as a result of treatment and in some
instances we resort to downright the
close to witchcraft that we throw what's
available clofazimine which is available
for leprosy linezolid which has been
used for mrs a we will use em oxy
clavulanate imipenem Carreiro bios
edison when you run out of options and
the treatment duration listed here is
based on the most recent regulations out
of the WHL group having done a review of
the literature published in the european
respiratory diseases journal basically
saying initial face compare that to the
two months used for drug susceptible
here you have eight months initial phase
and total duration instead of
approximately six to nine months of you
happen to have cat bilateral cafetaria
disease now you're talking about two
years of treatment it requires specialty
care monitoring of response management
of side effects and in fact the most
successful programs behave like programs
used for cancer therapy you know my
daughter had Hodgkin's in 1999 and she
was treated and they would tell her
you're going to develop nausea I'm going
to kill you kytril to prevent it from
happening you're going to have a
reaction i'm going to give you
hydrocortisone so that you we prevent
that the good programs will try to do
that for the patient's rather wait for
them to really experience the
devastating side effects of the drugs
then cycle searing drives you crazy I
mean it really has psychiatric
implications some people may require in
spite of all this surgical resection of
the affected lung lobe and the cost of
treatment breaks the bank we have
estimated in an unpublished study that
Suzanne marks just shared with me that
evaluating cases in the United States
the cost direct cost of care for persons
with multidrug-resistant TB ranges from
132 430,000 if you're talking about
xdr-tb it goes up to about four hundred
eighty eight thousand dollars and we
have at the extreme and a bell-shaped
distribution a person would cost a
million bucks to cure so you can imagine
a program that receives federal money in
the range of two to three hundred
thousand dollars per year you have one
of these patients that you're stuck with
and there goes your total budget the
outcomes are not good this work was done
by Evan Orenstein when he was here as an
undergrad at Yale working yeah I think
Gary and
others sent them to work into gaol ferry
this is a systematic review and
meta-analysis that shows that the pooled
treatment success of 34 studies is
sixty-four percent do you show there the
confidence interval between 59 and 68 it
is better if you used individualized
treatment that tailors and drugs to the
drug susceptibility pattern of the
culture positive tuberculosis so it's 64
versus fifty-four percent of you were to
use standardized regimens based on what
you know is happening in the community
using the drugs for more than 18 months
under directly observed therapy compared
with shorter no do t regimens the
outcomes are better 71 percent success
versus 58 and you can see the failure
default and death rates being really
high and unacceptable meta-analysis of
people with xdr-tb shows an overall
proportion of favorable outcomes about
forty four percent ranging from 33 to 55
to summarize that busy graph so this
compares with favorable outcomes of 97
to ninety-eight percent with drug septum
TV using the four drugs available to us
so the relapse rate should be no more
than two percent as opposed to this that
you are seeing I need to ignore that
although it is not a formally accepted
nosology there are reports out there
showing the occurrence of totally
drug-resistant tuberculosis from india
and i believe the other one is from Iran
the problem with calling it totally
drug-resistant TB is that no one tests
against all possible drugs I showed you
in a sly that we're recurring to drugs
are not available for a TB indication
yet are active against M tuberculosis to
do you call it tdr if you haven't tested
against lanessa would do you quality drv
haven't tested against clofazimine so
these are some of the challenges and
trying to come up with accepted
but suffice it to say that we are
confronted with patients who run out of
treatment options and that's what we
want so in our country national
surveillance started in 1953 for the
next three decades TB case greats came
down at a rate of about seven percent
fewer cases per year and that came to a
screeching halt in 1984 and we had a
reversal in trends in the United States
from nineteen eighty five to nineteen
ninety two there was a twenty percent
increase and Georgia cauthen working
with my cat whoa back then estimated
that had the original trend continued we
should have never seen what we call the
52,000 100 XS cases in our country
listed on the right hand side of the
slide are the associated conditions of
the erosion of the infrastructure TB
grants ceased to exist in the 1970s in
favor of block grants were state health
department's we're told you do what you
think you need to do with these monies
and TB was coming down they were
strapped for resources as and many of
these sites shut down their test clinics
when TB research we were very ill
prepared to respond to that then the
occurrence of HIV epidemic that gives
rise to large bowl of highly susceptible
individuals institutional transmission
because we had this invested in paying
attention to infection control
precautions multidrug-resistant TB and
immigration are all factors associated
with this next slide I will share some
of what we learned as a result of our
direct involvement in outbreak
investigations during those years first
was difficulties in diagnosing TB among
persons with HIV persons presented with
a typical clinical manifestations in
fact I remember seeing someone who
clinically I would have sworn this
person who has HIV has Pneumocystis
pneumonia bilateral interstitial
infiltrates and lo and behold sputum
smear microscopy
direct positive culture positive for TB
manifesting s PCP so the bathroom I was
using was not working and we needed to
switch gears right away lack of
real-time diagnostic results we saw
patients in whom drug susceptibility
results were coming back post morning I
mean this is unacceptable in my personal
opinion and the results were never used
to modify patient therapy there's a
reason for that this is a slow-growing
bug it takes ecoli any intestinal
bacteria 20 minutes to generate the
replica for a new generation it takes 24
hours for TB and as a result the solid
media took six weeks to identify if he
did drug susceptibility testing there
was another six weeks and you can
imagine the disaster and how we relevant
those results became for patient care
there was a total absence of infection
control precautions i remember reviewing
a medical record in one of the outbreaks
in new york and seeing written all over
the charts respiratory isolation yet
learning that the person was frequently
going out to the lounge this is back at
the good old days patients could smoke
in the hospital and that so they went to
the lounge on there is there smoking and
coughing this photograph was actually
taken I think it was Sam Dooley and one
of the outbreaks where one of the
patients who was supposed to be on
respiratory isolation is witness walking
past the nurse just showing his IV pole
wearing a surgical mask that's only tied
up at the top this is what the
implementation of rest of the victorious
elation was seemed to be at the time we
also saw the death in health care
workers and a personal guard and I'm
going to share with you because this was
very remarkable and turning the tide
against tuberculosis the cost of
recovery was inordinate Tom Frieden Rita
wasco and Peggy Hamburg have written
that it costs New York City about a
billion dollars to
from the resurgence of tuberculosis this
I've got over some of the challenges of
a typical clinical presentation then you
have the drug drug interactions you also
have immune reconstitution syndrome so
listen to me you're a doctor you're
supposed to make someone better you give
them drugs and they get worse what are
they going to think of you as I
practicing I'm going to seek medical
care somewhere else and we we've been
seeing this especially in sub-saharan
Africa where patients are lost when
practitioners are not anticipating the
occurrence of immune reconstitution
inflammatory syndrome and then the risk
of relapse as I've alluded to especially
with highly intermittent regimens this
slide comes out of a sem bleep uh
blessed by charles wells that i
contributed to it putting together all
the outbreaks our main outbreaks in New
York in Florida what we sell later in
Italy in Madrid Spain and Buenos Aires
Argentina in the prison in New York
State and i've added to the bottom of it
the dairy is a work that you and neil
Gandhi didn't to gala ferry because it
really was him it was yogi bear's deja
vu all over again occurring in ninety
and two up 2006 so you see the total
number of patients the proportion of
hiv-infected you know almost universal
HIV infection ninety two hundred percent
death rates hovering between 72 to
ninety-eight percent this is not what's
supposed to happen with the curable
disease and the time from diagnosis
death ranging from four to 16 weeks this
is galloping consumption at its best and
this is really what gave rise then to uh
oh i mentioned i pologize say this is a
slide from the correctional peace
officers foundation i found it online so
I'm not violating any private
information officer Petrosino died as a
result of having cared for patients who
were
are incarcerated with
multidrug-resistant TB and I have
boldface type the segment's petrosino
contracted multidrug-resistant
tuberculosis while keeping guard over
four inmates with AIDS on the same
strain of tuberculosis at the hospital
this brought the unions up in arms act
up oh and the healthcare work a union in
New York City we're saying what are you
doing to protect us we're not supposed
to be getting TB nor dying of it and
this in turn made it to the halls of
Congress who then opened their pocket
and gave us some money to respond to it
so this cartoon is that my effort to
summarize what we did to recover from
this mess we develop a national action
plan with a big bag of money we use it
to rebuilding infrastructure pay
attention to training to improve case
identification remind physicians and in
the setting of HIV infection that
clinical manifestations are different
you need to think differently suspect TB
focus on the use of directly observed
therapy as a proven adherence measure to
then pay attention to outreach and
improve a complete sort of therapy for
tuberculosis we also invested in
updating the diagnostic lab capacity woo
we move from solid me to it to liquid
media to cut the turnaround time in half
of what it used to be and get drug
susceptibility test results I could be
used to guide treatment the other thing
was invested in developing infection
control and overall treatment
recommendations and rebuilt the research
capacity which had really lapsed since
we thought to be conquered 20 years
later as reported in last writings I'm
on WR we are at a historic low in the
United States we have fewer than 10,000
incident tuberculosis cases for a rate
of 3.2 400,000 but that still means that
27 new people will debate
angles with TB in this country by the
end of today and the job is not done our
goal is to eliminate TB which is to
achieve a rate of one per million so
we're 32 times higher than where we need
to be what has happened with HIV
co-infection if you look at all ages in
red it went from about fifteen percent
co-infections six percent in the most
recent year in the younger age group in
blue 25 to 44 went to from 29 now
hovering around eleven percent we've
also seen that in 2012 all states and
the District of Columbia reported at
least one case of tuberculosis the range
of state specific rates nationally it's
3.2 is low of 0.4 500,000 and West
Virginia to a high of 9 in Alaska 33
states had lower rates in 2012 compared
to 2011 and four states produce about
fifty percent of all cases California
Texas New York and Florida this is the
new map of the country showing in blue
states reporting lower than national
case rates and in red the 13 states and
the District of Columbia reporting
higher than national average you in
Connecticut happen to be surrounded by
red states by the way this is not meant
to imply voting practices when we look
at the profile of those with
tuberculosis in 2012 we see that we now
have tuberculosis mostly in minority
racial and ethnic groups only sixteen
percent of persons reported with TB in
the united states were non-hispanic
white thirty-one percent asian
twenty-eight percent Hispanic twenty-two
percent to black if you look at the
rates by practicing numerator
denominator you see that the rates and
each and every single one of these
groups
several times higher than in white with
the highest rate ratio happening between
Asian and whites 25 times higher the
other change we've seen is that other
risk factors that continue to occur our
homelessness accounting for five point
six percent of the cases but that
doesn't tell you the true story I went
back the National Association for the
homeless has some denominator data the
most recent I could find was 2011 so I
compared it so the rate of tuberculosis
and homeless that year was 88.8 that was
26 times higher than the general
population rate of tuberculosis in that
year we also see excess alcohol use and
residents in a correctional facility
which underestimates the true magnitude
of the impact of having been
incarcerated on tuberculosis because the
way that the data are reported at CDC
are if someone is diagnosed with
tuberculosis at a time when they've been
incarcerated so all these people who
come in and out of the correctional
facility are not appropriately accounted
for in this particular setting we also
see that the profile has turned mostly
to foreign-born the number has decreased
as you see in the histograms for the
u.s. born population the foreign-born
shown in blue has remained relatively
stable and now sixty-three percent in
2012 were foreign-born the rates for the
foreign-born have come down from 34 to
15.7 in 2012 in the US born from 7.4 to
1.4 so the good news is that their
trends are both going in the right
direction but there remains of high and
significant gap in the United States and
2011 I don't yet have the 2012 data
there were 127 incident cases or
one-point-six percent of all culture
confirmed cases thank you for eighty
five point eight percent of MDR cases
are in foreign born and there was only
one next dr in 2012 but that reflects
the global reality TV continues to
account for 8.7 million persons of whom
1.1 million are HIV infected the
prevalence of MDR is thought to be
630,000 but only one out of every five
gets reported in the world the incidence
of tuberculosis by population is highest
in sub-saharan Africa where eighty
percent of HIV co-infected tuberculosis
occurs in the world if you look at sheer
numbers the largest number of cases come
from Southeast Asia followed by Africa
than western Pacific and fewer numbers
from the Americas in the case of
multidrug-resistant tuberculosis the
highest numbers this is numerator data
alone come from India and China followed
by Eastern European countries and you
have a smattering of sort of
intermediate rates in South Africa and
other parts of Africa but you will see
also not so clearly in this slide
prepared by wh 0 that we are ignorant
about the true extent of drug-resistant
tuberculosis because we're not measuring
it consistently throughout the world at
our own peril the global control
programs over the last six years have
had remarkable achievements 51 million
persons have been treated 20 million
life saved eight forty-eight percent of
hiv-infected TB have been started on
antiretrovirals there's been a reversal
in the general epidemic and the
Millennium Development Goals on
mortality are on track globally however
the incidence is declining far too
slowly globally one-third of the cases
are not in the system not getting
reported we're lagging behind on the MDR
TB response with IE alluded to twenty
percent so nineteen percent of MDR is
reported
and mortality decline in Africa in
Europe is not on track for achieving the
goals so that's a reality in the world
and let me just move very quickly
because I had asked for a 15-minute mark
I have about five more minutes of slides
but I really would like to engage with
you rather have you listened to me so we
are in the United States at a place that
I call the paradox of low incidence Oh
sudden we're seeing credential
practitioners in our country who have no
proficiency nor expertise in
tuberculosis that lead to delays in
diagnosis I was having breakfast this
morning with the folks from Connecticut
Matt car girl in Sosa and Mark Lobato
and they were telling me about an
analysis of deaths in Connecticut for
the last few years and showing that most
of it is accounted for by delays and
diagnosis I mean that's the impact of
that loss of proficiency there's also
the return of complacency this
propensity of us as human beings to
declare prematurely the problem has been
solved let's divert our attention to the
next disease the juror the deceased
concentration as I hope I've shown you
is increasingly geographically
concentrated also in vulnerable
populations such as homeless and the
foreign-born and I highlight these two
because I'm very concerned that the
nation moves forward thinking that
Affordable Care Act is could be a
solution to our problems i invite you to
show me who has made provisions to
provide a safety net for these types of
individuals then the ongoing outbreaks
of TB are continuously unveiling that
the laser and diagnosis contribute to
ongoing transmission the limited support
to monitor therapy are resulting in
relapses the emergence of resistance and
ongoing transmission and then to add
insult to injury the United States of
America an established market economy is
experiencing shortages of isoniazid and
other anti-tb drugs we had to
right in the end of 2012 that isoniazid
was on short supply and we're trying to
come up with remedies so that people
don't go untreated because you don't
have the drug available to them second
line drugs have been chronically in
short supply the national TV controllers
Association did this survey that was
reported in the MMWR out of 26 36 is 21
eighty-one percent face challenges in
obtaining second line medications and as
you see down below fifty eight percent
resulting in delays and starting
treatment thirty-two percent in
treatment interruptions and thirty-two
percent in having to resort to
inadequate regimens for the treatment of
these persons so in my personal opinion
if we're going to arrive at elimination
we need to bridge three gaps I call it
the implementation knowledge and
ambition gap what do i mean about that
well the implementation gap has been
written about by others before Wallace
Fox who was really the person who
propelled the British Medical Research
Council do the stage that have yielded
the multi drug treatment regimens that
we rely upon in 1963 lamented and quotes
little attempt to adapt present no to
their specific problems when referring
to many of the countries where the
studies were done like Indian East
Africa dr. Fendall at the new york
academy of sciences in 1972 refers to
medicine in the 20th century as quote
superb in technological breakthroughs
but woefully inept in its application of
notes those most in need further he
suggests that the implementation gap
must be closed what are we doing we in
the United States have seen that this
battle is not going to be conquered and
we just stay within our borders we need
to invest in global TB control this
study done by Kevin Schwartzman in the
late 1990s showed that if the US and
Canada invested in improving TV programs
in Mexico and Haiti we would reduce the
incidence of
closes at a return for the investment I
don't have the exact figures we've seen
below also Betsy McKay from Wall Street
Journal writing about the recent
occurrence of MDR and the fact that
eighty-five percent of MDR in our
country is a reflection of what's
happening elsewhere and this is the
cover of a recent Time magazine called
contagion the other thing I think we
need to do and is something we're
challenge is to redefine what are those
core Public Health functions that must
be protected at all costs and I share
with you some thoughts that we've had
back in the past some things come back
in cycles we working with Sara Rosenbaum
published a report entitled TB control
and a changing healthcare system and
issued model contract specifications for
managed care organizations the other
thing that we need to make sure we
protect is a core lab capacity and the
Advisory Council for elimination of
tuberculosis back in nineteen
ninety-five listed the essential core
components of a TV program we to
articulate them I don't care who doesn't
that but they need to be done and and
that I think it's going to be our
challenge as we move ahead the other
thing is keep your eye on the target
what are your indices whether they're
met by a private provider by a federally
funded facility or the Health Department
program are you our persons with TV
being found getting cured to the
individual we're ultimately accountable
for all these persons and we have a
series of targets that we have that we
need to keep track of at CC we've had
these as the national TV program
indicator targets in order to try to
protect the repository of expertise we
have funded five regional training and
magic
medical consultation centers in a
California Texas the newest one is Mayo
New Jersey has been there for a while
and Florida and what we've done is we
develop agreements so that these sites
are responsible for the contiguous
states that are color-coded so that if
you happen to be a practitioner in
Connecticut and you want expertise you
can pick up the phone and the rtm CC in
New Jersey should be able to respond to
that at no cost to you that's made for
you by your taxes if it's not happening
I want to know about it the other thing
we're doing is we're revising the
federal funding formula to try to track
the changing epidemiology to support the
core program basics provide incentives
for improving performance the safety net
that I brief refer to support human
resource development and training adds
flexibility for response to outbreaks
that are continuing I was just hearing
from folks who are deployed in Los
Angeles County we're an ongoing outbreak
in the homeless community that has made
the news has now resulted in about close
to 18,000 potentially exposed
individuals who are going to need to be
found and evaluated for their
tuberculosis I've also alluded to the
need to align domestic and global
activities given that two out of every
three persons in our country emanate
from the global tuberculosis epidemic we
also cannot disinvest in research for
innovation and program improvement and
that brings me to the knowledge cap we
need to locally have a better
understanding of the epidemiology and
the drivers of transmission I think that
we can aspire and should aspire to same
day diagnosis of tuberculosis and drug
resistance result to guide optimal
treatment we should find a way to come
up with regimens that cure people I deal
in two to three months I'll take four
months I'm a good negotiator I will you
know if you show me that you can achieve
98
cure with a four-month regiment I'll
take it understanding the genetic
markers of bacterial virulence to enable
targeted interventions it's going to be
key we're ignorant we have incredible
lacuna in our understanding of our body
handles and develops immune correlative
protection the host defenses and of
course the vaccine would be the ideal I
wanted to share with you that because
part of the knowledge gap is I can we
use modeling to help direct our actions
this is a series of graphs and I've just
selected out of modeling that we
published adjusted in 2011 projections
of TB and the foreign-born and the
us-born and then all combined we're not
going to get elimination in the
foreign-born we could however if we
increase to four times the baseline the
identification of persons with latent TB
and get them successfully treated and
cured we could be at the one per million
mark by 2022 so but it takes doing that
it doesn't take wishing for it and just
to share with you that based on the best
on latest available estimate we think
that there are anywhere from nine to 14
million persons in the United States
with latent tuberculosis infection not
surprisingly the rate of infection is
ten times higher in the foreign versus
u.s. born and then those with a low
poverty index as defined and the
footnote have rates that are almost
twice as high and you also see the rates
higher in non-hispanic blacks we've
repeated this survey in the national
health and nutrition study and later
this year I should have updated
information for the years 2012 and 2013
to see if we still have these many or
ideally it's fewer other aspects of
knowledge gap that have yielded results
is the investment by the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation actually David
Holland who also trained with Jerry
while we were at montefiore
has helped develop what I call the
expressive machine approach to
diagnosing tuberculosis you take a
sputum sample put it the actually
inactivate it but then put a pipette it
into a cartridge put it into this module
90 minutes later you have a diagnosis of
TV on whether rifampin resistance is
present or not rifampin resistance is an
indicator of MDR circuit indicator the
other thing is that as a result of
studies Janssen therapeutics recently
established the efficacy of bed aculon
diarrheal quinlan as an effective drug
as part of the regimen and treating
persons with MDR and for the first time
in over 40 years FDA has approved a new
drug for a TV indication using the
accelerator program mechanism for
life-threatening conditions this is
limited for to MDR that challenges us to
then transform that into new policy how
are we going to use it who's going to
have access to it and all that is are
still unresolved questions other new
technology is using genetic sequencing
to read the DNA rather than wait for the
slow growing bug to grow we have shown
and cc's offering a service that using
sequencing we can detect mutations in
non lo sai that confer assistance 27
anti-tb drugs results available in two
days rather than the 42 day turnaround
time if you go down the usual path
another recent finding is establishing
the efficacy in the United States of
using isoniazid and repenting for three
months once weekly under directly
observed therapy 12 doses your treatment
is completed we develop guidelines on
I'm wanting to make sure that they're
all doubt but that we do post post
rollout evaluation of safety of this the
Holy Grail is of course TB vaccines and
the good news is that there's a
relatively robust pipeline and Mike
Brennan who you
to be at FDA has written about this in
the International Journal of TB and lung
diseases and the citation is right there
I would invite you if you're interested
to take a look at that the ambition gap
is I think where we fall short we really
what I have seen is that TV programs
have operated under poor conditions for
so long that there's an impoverishment
of will common to resource-limited
settings and we need to overcome that we
need to acknowledge that TV elimination
and eradication are the ultimate goals
for either a present or future
generation but you're not going to stop
running a marathon before you cross that
finish line we need to mobilize
political resolve we need to develop a
solidarity of effort and I think we need
to develop a status of in tolerability
where if you see TB that means
something's wrong because we shouldn't
be seeing this disease we need to keep
that pole down bishan expectations and
sustained actions and as I say no room
for premature declarations of victory
political commitment here's a form of it
this is the legislation that authorizes
the comprehensive TBL nation act for
five years what's interesting is that
there's a remarkable difference between
authorized and appropriated dollars we
are receiving about a hundred million
fewer dollars and we are authorized to
receive in 2013 under a continuing
resolution by the way the Stop TB USA in
2010 developed a call for action and we
helped you establish some of these
parameters so if we were to eliminate TB
by 2035 there'd be nearly a quarter
million fewer TB cases over 15,000 fewer
deaths and 1.3 billion lesson treatment
costs using two thousand six dollars
globally it's been estimated that we
would need to invest 4.8 million of
which 3.2 are available the government's
are investing investing already the
funding gap is 1.6 billion but the
anticipated yield as 17 million people
treated six million lives would be saved
in closing I want to share with you I'm
a big fan and a student of Bill faigy
who is our agency director when I first
arrived at CC and Bill was involved in
this ballpark eradication campaign and
he's recently written his own accounting
of it and in this book shown here
entitled house on fire and his words
really resonate with me he said you know
to achieve this thousands of people
participated in a spawn global
eradication effort they were optimists
they were risk takers there was no
shortage of people telling them that the
effort was futile and it wasn't science
that threatened to stop us it was even
nature per se it was human nature the
human factors that involve strikes job
security political concerns are in turf
so I posit to you that if we are able to
overcome this we should be seeing t be
eliminated in summary I've shared with
you that over the last 20 years we've
had a recovery from it the devastating
impact of the resurgence of
hiv-associated multidrug-resistant TB
achieving elimination requires
sustaining the recent gains and bridging
the gaps in the three areas that I
mentioned and the Institute of Medicine
said it best in their report entitled
ending neglect published by the National
Academy of Sciences in the year 2000 the
issue now confronting the nation is
whether we will allow another cycle of
neglect to begin or instead we whether
we will take decisive action to
eliminate tuberculosis I hope you join
me and staying on with this fight until
we see this disease eliminated and
instead of commemorating the date when
Robert [ __ ] discovered the bacillus we
drink a glass of champagne to its
elimination so thank you for your
attention